so i was talking to an entrepreneur who
had applied through acquisition.com to
potentially become a portfolio company
and one of the questions that i asked on
the call was so what's your ltv like how
much you know how much you make per
customer of a lifetime and he honestly
was like i don't know what what it is i
know i should know blah blah blah so i'm
making this video so that you know one
of the most important metrics in
entrepreneurship and i'll give you three
different ways you can calculate it i'm
gonna try and remember i had three
before i started this video but when i'm
on video sometimes i forgot so the first
one and the easiest one to do this is
off of lifetime the second way to do it
is off of churn and the third way is to
do it is off sales velocity all right
and i'll finish with sales velocity
because it's the one that i use most
frequently but all of these are good
ways of getting and i'll give you
approximations and i'll explain how each
of them is calculated now as a quick
side note the reason that this is so
important if you don't know who i am
acquisitions.com i own it with a
portfolio it's about 100 million here
nothing to sell you i just make these
videos because i like doing this and i'm
a crazy person and i am what appears to
be looks like i'm in a closet uh which i
am actually in a closet because i don't
like having windows where i work and i
wear a wife beater out of choice rather
than necessity anyways so let's rock and
roll with the three ways to calculate
ltv okay if you are a growing business
this will under estimate your ltv but if
you have especially recurring like
recurring and it's you've been doing
this for a while and you are growing
what you do is let's say that you did uh
you know one million dollars year one
you did two million year two and you did
three million year three all right let's
just say that for a simple example and
let's say over over that entire period
of time you sold let's say
600 customers okay
so what you do here is you add these up
which means you have six million in
total sales lifetime over 600 total
customers lifetime all right and so this
will give you the the it's just this is
again back of napkin math of how to get
to how much you make per customer so
it'd be 6 million divided by 600 which
is probably like 10 grand i'm guessing
it's 10k
and so that would give you an
underestimation because you will have
customers who are still continuing to
pay you so if you it gives you basically
from the beginning until now but it
doesn't take the future into account so
it will be under what it is in theory
but this will give you something to work
off of so that's number one so that's
this guy let me give you a highlight
that's this one all right now the second
way that you can calculate lcv is based
on churn and if you don't know what turn
is it's going to be the percentage of
customers that leave
at the end of the month that were here
at the beginning of the month so let's
say you have 100 customers at the
beginning of the month and let's say of
those hundred you've got 95 at the end
note that the amount of questions you
sell sold between here and here does not
matter in this calculation all right
just because people get really [ __ ] up
with this so if 100 customers at the
beginning you have 95 at the end it
means you had five that left
and you do five divided by 100
right which means you have five percent
turn all right that is your churn very
simple okay now if you're like well i
had some people cancel beginning again
all of these are rough estimates because
you can't ever have a beautiful snapshot
in a business ever because time is a
component that fudges the world all
right so once you have churn this is how
you use that churn so you take your
price your average monthly price so
let's say you've got 100 people and
you're making whatever 100 000 a month
uh so you've got 100k per month divided
by 100 people which means you're making
a thousand dollars per month per client
that says client go for it okay it says
client so that's our average price and
we divide that which is this thing right
you divide that by your turn so a
thousand divided by five percent would
be 20x
1k which equals 20k so that is your ltv
and so if i had this business and let's
say they were stable at a hundred
thousand dollars a month i would know
that they're probably only selling five
new clients a month pretty interesting
now if they're selling more than that
then i know that they are actually
growing and they haven't realized or
tapped out what their with their new
revenue threshold is going to be kind of
interesting this is why it's important
another stuff as an entrepreneur because
you might be like why isn't it growing
faster but if you're in the situation
you've got five percent churn you're
doing a thousand dollars a month you've
got 100 customers and you're selling 20
a month then your hypothetical max is
gonna be 400k so you don't need to
change anything you just gotta wait and
you're gonna have 400k a month all right
that's why ltv is so important to
understand how to calculate it all right
so you can do it off lifetime which i
showed you first the second way you can
do this off churn and the third way is
off sales velocity and this is the one
that i do most commonly and the reason
for that is because the lifetime
i mean it'll give you an approximation
and this is important especially if you
have like a low
price very high volume like recurring
membership lifetime one is helpful with
churn you can do this uh that one is
also useful for that but it's more of a
hypothetical and sometimes it
overestimates it so you're going to want
to average out your turn because let's
say you get five percent turn one month
but you had 20 the month before and 13
the month that you know before that so
you want to average your turnout be like
all right well we average 12 right and
then you use that as the churn number
that you use the calculation to
calculate for the business and you want
to do it the most recently because if
you all of a sudden start selling more
but then your term goes up that is the
new those are the new metrics your
business you can't use your churn from a
year ago when you were only selling
one-off people and now you have a sales
machine but you're not doing as well in
fulfillment because you don't have
enough personalized attention right
that's why this is so important now
sales velocity this is the third way to
calculate this so sales velocity number
three is you say how many people are you
selling per month you just ask them and
you can say like last three months what
are you averaging let's say they say 10
people per month is what we're averaging
in new sales all right this is important
new sales now i'll say what are you
doing in revenue now the reason the
sales velocity one or the conditions on
which this one works is if the revenue
has remained relatively the same so for
the last three or four months let's say
they've been at a hundred thousand ish a
month all right now that they're they're
at a point of stagnation all right or
close enough stagnation that we can use
it for a calculation so let's say 100k a
month is what they uh we're averaging in
their business and they're selling 10 10
deals a month you know where this is
going then i can tell them that the
rough estimate for their ltv is going to
be 10k and that gives you a good idea
because if they're just maintaining it
this then it means they're losing some
they're gaining new ones and they're
staying at that level which means
they've already hit that point of
equilibrium and so all of the thing with
ltv is the relationship between sales
velocity and how much a client's worth
and so the turn calculation showed a
little bit more depth around pricing and
turn to get the ltv right number but all
of it gets around to answer the simple
question which is how much the customer
worth to us and then from there we can
make better decisions and so when we're
looking at companies we want to see
companies with strong ltvs or the
potential to have strong ltvs so that in
the future we could spend more in the
acquisition and scale the business right
and a lot of times this is one of the
weakest points in uh in companies
especially in that three to ten million
range is that they don't actually make
enough per customer their mars start
getting squeezed which compresses their
ability to scale i'm gonna go a little
deeper on this on this concept of using
ltv to project and i just want you guys
to know like i'm not an excel whiz like
i had to learn this stuff because like
i'm just not i just haven't naturally
been that good at it so i had to learn
the back of napkin way of doing business
and i'll be real with you just about
every major business system i make i
just make it on back of napping because
even the most precise calculations can
still be done off of rough data sets and
so you got to just understand like where
your gut is and just kind of like the
directional math around the stuff so
let's say we have i'm going to give you
two scenarios so we'll give you scenario
a it's an error b this is important
because it will help you make decisions
for your business about what to do to
grow all right so let's say we've got a
business that's that's selling let's say
10 people a month and they're doing uh a
hundred thousand dollars per month and
their churn is and let's say their their
price point is whatever let's say it's
uh 5 000 a month is the price of what
they're selling for these 10 people
right and let's say their churn is uh 20
all right so that's that's the numbers
that we have in scenario one all right
so this is new sales and let's say we
have the same the same ones so we have
new sales let's say it's 10. let's say
price points 5k a month and let's say
that they're doing 500k per month and
their turn is 20
now let's see the difference between
these two scenarios all right so if we
have a 10k per month sorry 10 10 clients
per month and they're selling at 5k and
we know churn is 20
then what do we have to figure out we
have to figure out the lifetime value
right and so if we take the 5k per month
and we divided by the 20 turn we're
gonna have a 25k ltv
right this makes sense now if we're
selling 10 new people a month then it
means that this business is going to
continue to grow and it'll slow down at
250 000 per month this is a back of
napkin way that you can do projections
so think about it if we have 10 new
clients and they're signing up at 5 000
we're adding 50 000 a month but we're
also losing 20 percent and so as we the
first month we'll make 50. the next
month we'll do 50 plus 40 right in the
next month we'll do 50 plus 40 plus 30.
right so it continues towards this
asymptote which means it approaches zero
but it approaches a number but it
doesn't actually hit it so this is the
asymptote
so 250 250 000 is the asymptote and at
that point we'd have to change something
that this would have to change the price
we have to change the term the churn
we'd have to change the number of uh new
sales that are happening in order to
grow this business now if i'm talking to
somebody here or you are that person
there then i know that this thing is
growing which is great even if we change
something the business can continue to
grow awesome now here's the flip side
let's say we have that same scenario 10
5 except the only difference here is
it's at 500 000 a month right well if we
know that this thing is going to cap out
right at 250k the line's going to look
different because it's going to do this
so it's going to drop dramatically in
the beginning and then it's going to
even out at 250k so if i'm talking to
this business then i know that they're
at 500 today and this guy's at 100k
today
but they're both going towards 250 000
because that is the reality of the
business so if you're selling 10 a month
at 5k with 20 churn your business does
250 000. that is what i want you to take
away with this is that you will know and
understand what your cap rate or your
hypothetical max is for your business
simply by doing the math and so you'll
know if you have the capacity to grow
you are you're on a shrinking curve or
what's common is you're in scenario c
right which is you're at 250 000 a month
you're selling 10 people per month at 5k
per month and your turn is 20
and you're stagnant like this which
means that one of these things must
change we either have to sell more
people we've got to change the price we
gotta add add some zeros to the price or
we have to fix the churn now here's
where it's kind of interesting if we can
fix the churn of this business let's say
we just get it from 20
to 10 turn doesn't seem like it's a big
difference does it it's a hell of a
difference and so if you're thinking
about the leverage that you're going to
pull in your business you could say all
right if i wanted to get to let's say a
million a month which is probably common
for somebody who's at this stage right
they want to get to a million a month
that's their next objective well let's
talk about the ways they can get there
all right scenario number one to get to
a million a month we could start selling
40 people a month right and change
nothing else we start selling 40 people
a month equals 1 million per month all
right because we just forexed this
number the second way we can get to a
million dollars a month is we could
forex this price we could start selling
20k per month right with the same number
of sales and that'll get us to a million
a month assuming turn stays the same the
third scenario is that we would so
that's this one the third scenario is
that we would reduce churn to five
percent and change nothing else which of
these seems easiest well forexing price
might be difficult right that might be
uh
you know represents a serious risk to
the likelihood you know the value
exchange might not be there and so you'd
probably not choose this guy this one
probably wouldn't be the first bet right
so then you're pretty much left with i'm
going to either forex the number of
sales which means i need to spend more
money on ads or i got to do more reach
out so i got to do more posts or get
more affiliates or get more word of
mouth whatever or i got to work on my
back end and reduce churn here's the
interesting tidbit if you fix this
right
if you fix that it's easier to fix churn
and then do this and then all of a
sudden you're at four million a month
this is why business is fun and so that
is how like that's how we approach
business problems in acquisition.com
it's like okay what are the biggest
levers that we can use to transform this
business using the biggest rocks that we
have available to us and i wanted to
make this video because i think it's
important to think through these
business problems um strategically so
you can think what are these which of
these levers can i pull that as the
highest likelihood and here's the
problem if you do this in a different
direction let's say you 4x the sales you
get to 40 a month you're going to build
infrastructure you can do this other
stuff but the problem is you might have
built infrastructure too quickly and the
people that you hire suck and then you
can't get the churn down right and then
you also can't fix things properly and
so you basically feel like you have to
keep selling to keep to keep just keep
the business afloat even though you know
that you have this 20 turn which is
killing your business and so in order to
make this thing a sellable business or
have a business of value or enterprise
value is we have to fix the product we
have to fix the client experience so
that people actually want to continue to
pay for this thing right i guess my four
million a month got cut off here this is
four million a month there you go
and so this is how you can think
strategic because if you fix the back
end first then guess what happens your
ltv quadrupled now you can go and spend
whatever you want in the acquisition and
still be profitable whereas in this
scenario you probably have to compress
your margins because usually when you
increase acquisition margin two get
compressed but you already compress them
right like you didn't expand them to
begin with so let's say you were at a 30
margin then you four extra sales now
you're at a 10 margin that sucks and so
we want to do is we want to expand the
margin expand the lifetime gross profit
per customer by extending the ltv
through churn and
creating a better experience better
product better product market fix match
excuse me and then at that point then
you can open up the opportunity to scale
like crazy and so this is definitely a
more technical video than i normally
make and that is because i like to mix
it in with some of the life stuff
because i do love business probably more
than just about anything business is
awesome and so if you can speak in these
terms you will impress people and more
importantly you will impress yourself
because you'll have more tools in your
entrepreneurial toolbox and if this was
at all interesting to you please let me
know in the comments because i'll make
more maybe i'll do a little series on
like entrepreneurial toolkits or uh
things like that but otherwise keeping
awesome mozy nation i love you if you
don't know who i am or you're new to the
channel my name is oxmoozy on
acquisition.com portfolio company says
100 million plus a year and i have
nothing to sell you alright keeping
awesome see you next video bye